Princess Savitri of the Madra Kingdom
was as benevolent, brilliant, and bright
as the Sun God she was named for.
Her grace was known throughout the land,
and many powerful princes and wealthy
merchants flocked to her family’s palace
to seek her hand in marriage.
But upon witnessing her blinding splendor
in person,
the men lost their nerve.
Unimpressed with these suitors,
the princess determined
to find a husband herself.
Mounting her golden chariot,
she travelled through rolling deserts,
glittering cities
and snow-capped mountains—
rejecting many men along the way.
Eventually, Savitri ventured
deep into the jungle,
where she met a young man
chopping wood.
His name was Satyavan, and like her,
he loved the tranquil forest—
but the princess saw he was not at peace.
After talking for hours, Satyavan told
her of his plight.
His parents had once been wealthy rulers,
until his father was blinded
and overthrown in a violent coup.
Now Satyavan worked tirelessly
to support their meager new life.
His determination and devotion
moved the princess.
As they gazed into each other’s eyes,
she knew she’d finally found an equal.
Savitri rushed home to tell
her father the good news,
only to find him conversing with Narada
a traveling sage and wisest messenger
of the Gods.
At first her father was thrilled
to learn of Satyavan,
but Narada revealed a tragic prophecy:
her betrothed had only a year to live.
Savitri’s blood ran cold.
She’d waited so long to find her partner—
was she already doomed to lose him?
The princess would not accept these terms.
She swore before Narada, her family,
and Savitr himself that she would
never marry another.
Satyavan was her one true love,
and their fates were entwined forever.
Moved by her powerful words,
the sage told the princess to follow
an ancient spiritual regimen.
With regular prayer, periods of fasting,
and preparation of special
herbs and plants,
she might be able to prolong
Satyavan’s life.
After a simple wedding, the couple
returned to the jungle to live
in keeping with the sage’s instructions.
This modest existence was a far cry
from her lavish upbringing,
but they were happy in each other’s
company.
A year passed, and the fated day arrived.
On their first anniversary,
the sun grew horribly hot,
and Satyavan’s brow began to burn,
Savitri barely had time to drag
him into the shade,
before he grew still and cold.
Through her tears, the princess
saw an immense figure on the horizon.
This was Yamraj, the God of Death,
come to escort Satyavan’s soul
to the afterlife.
But Savitri was not giving up yet.
She followed the god for hours
in the beating sun.
Yamraj thundered at the princess
to leave him in peace.
But even as her feet bled and throat
burned, Savitri would not turn back.
Eventually, Yamraj paused.
He would grant her one wish
as reward for her persistence,
but she couldn’t ask
for her husband’s life.
Without hesitating, Savitri asked the God
to restore her father in-law’s sight.
The wish was granted, and Yamraj rode on.
But still Savitri’s footsteps
echoed behind him.
Exasperated, the God granted
her a second wish.
This time, she asked for Satyavan’s
kingdom to be restored.
Again the wish was granted,
and Yamraj began his descent
into his subterranean kingdom.
But when he glanced back,
he was astounded to see
the bedraggled princess stumbling along.
He’d never seen such devotion to the dead,
and he honored her dedication
with one final wish.
Savitri wished to be the mother
of many children.
The God agreed, and waved to dismiss her.
But the princess only repeated the vow
she’d made one year earlier:
her fate was forever entwined
with Satyavan.
How could she bear many children,
if Yamraj would not return her husband?
Hearing this clever question the god
relented, knowing he’d been beaten.
With Yamraj’s blessing and respect,
Satyavan was returned to Savitri,
and the two walked back
to the land of the living,
united in a love that not even
death could destroy.